okay
great that you're here uh my name is
ivan ordin i'm one of the developers of
system modeler
i work here in champaign to get together
with me today we have leonardo
from the math core team in sweden we
also have analy
from the math core team in sweden um and
this talk is actually three talks so the
price of one talk you get three
and uh it's it's gonna follow the the
the outline that i have up here so we're
going to start with the system modern
education focusing
a little bit on how system other is
doing in academia
what uh what's happening in there after
that anneli will present on a
applied example with system modeler in
in a hydraulic configuration for
airplanes and look a little bit at fault
analysis there
and then we've saved the best for last
leonardo is
doing a talk on connectivity and
connecting devices to system modeler and
different ways to use your models in
other systems
so that's really interesting and i'm
looking forward to hearing that too
so um system modelling education
first of all if you look briefly at the
timeline of system modeler in 2012 we
released
the first wolfram branded system modeler
version 3.0 before that it was called
math modelica in 2014
um this year we released system modeler
4 with the substantial updates
and i've mentioned as a separate bullet
there that we have
a library store and this library store
gives
us a possibility to continuously add
updates
to system monitor without updating the
full software
well why does that matter well because
if you want a new functionality in
system modeler
you can use a library or develop a
library and when you have a library you
can
distribute that on our library store
so just yesterday we released new
library called model plug
it connects arduino's to system modeler
and that's one of the things that
leonardo will show
later today
one of the things that we discovered for
our first time users
people that haven't seen system modeler
before maybe haven't done modeling and
simulation before
is that it's a it has been a steep
learning curve
and we're doing a lot of things to kind
of help a smooth this learning curve out
so that you
have different help systems available at
all times
so uh some of the things here that i
want to point out that we've done in
version four
is a new book uh creating components
from mathematica
and also a real time link so let's look
a little bit at
these three things
first we've sponsored a book
that's integrated into system modeler
it's called modelica by example
and if actually if you follow this book
you'll get kind of a good
introduction to to modelica building
components in different domains so
it's it's a good resource to have
together with this book there's also a
integrated it's integrated into our help
system
so for instance if i open the book here
and look
at look at that book here
you can see that directly and
if you're interested in in a certain
thing say that you're interested in
learning about inductor you can type
that up
and the search will help you find things
that are relevant to that topic
so for instance here inductor you can
see that that's a part of the
library documentation there's a
search a search result for something
that's in this book modelica
by example and there are things that are
related to
this inductor for the system modeler
documentation
and in the system modeler documentation
you can see that
there is an inductor being used
somewhere throughout this this document
so that's one way to
to help students get up and ready
the other thing is to to help people
develop their components usually when
you build new components you can do
something like this here
here is a model of a car
you drag and drop components connect
them together build the system
or you go the hard way around you type
in equations manually
in modelica code and you get you do
something that looks like this
well to help you with this
we've developed a interface in
mathematica
where you can type up equations directly
in
mathematica and then use our new super
function
system modeler create model to create
something that does exactly this so this
equation that i have now has
now been generated and it's available as
a model
in system modeler so it says there that
i have a new block
an ad block and that's now available in
my
my components and i can use this
in a model like this and then directly
simulate and see what happens to that
um that model
so there we can try that actually
input in the output for that thing
moving on another thing that's important
when you're learning a system is to get
this kind of immediate feedback
so if you're developing a web page you
can see okay i typed this code
this is what it looks like now
that's something that that we've had for
a long time in terms of mathematica with
dynamic interactivity
well now we have a very similar thing in
system modeler 2
with real-time simulations driven from
mathematica
so here i have a model it's a very
simplistic model i take this
sine wave i add some data
by myself and i look at the output so
i'll take this model
and use it as an argument to real time
simulate
i can start that simulation and then i
attach
from the dynamic i take
an angular gauge here that's that's a
graphics construct that's that's
directly available in mathematica
then i set up
this signal to be the input
in that model there
and then when i plot
i can directly change the input
and see how that affects the the output
there
so as i change the gauge here
the sine wave will will follow my signal
so in this way it's
it's easy to build up an intuitive
feeling for
what your models are are doing and you
can see how they react to your
your stimulus
and the other day i was just searching
around i found this video on youtube so
this is kind of
one user case of how people are are
adapting adopting a system modeler
throughout
at michigan tech there's a professor
teaching
with mathematics and system modeler kind
of helping people
uh get started with with a notebook
interface and
uh in system modeler here another such
use case
it is ben gurion university
in israel doing
building models for radio communications
if you're more interested in this story
yehuda is here at the conference you can
talk about him
and talk with him about this or you can
follow this link and see
see the full user story it's also linked
from the system water webpage
to help kind of grow the interest in
this area we're
writing a series of blog posts and you
can see these blog posts coming
through on on the wolfram blog
here's an example from an
electrical engineering blog that i wrote
i'm taking
a high frequent and low frequent
signal adding them together and then
passing them through
a filter so if we look at this
you can see those those two signals
there
can use the
fourier functionality in mathematica to
directly
get out a fourier spectrum for that so
you can see
uh what the frequency of that noise that
i'm adding there
to it so it's it's it makes for kind of
intuitive
uh explorations in in different fields
if we look at an upcoming blog here this
is
in mechanical engineering and if we if
we just take a
step back and think a little bit about
it why are we using system modern
education
what's the the key one of
what are the key benefits that it brings
well if i would
hide the that the topic of this or the
the uh the label of this thing
would you be able to tell what it what
it does well that system
is is you can see that it's a system it
has some integrators but it's
it's almost impossible to see what is
the system that i'm
modeling so um
this is this is what you would do if
you're in a
block based world you're using blocks to
model your systems
here's a link to where i found this and
you know
it took me a couple of minutes to
drag the the components
available in system modeler to create
the equivalent system
and then it took me another five minutes
to
set the correct parameters for for how
big the masses are
and here you can directly see that it's
a suspension system you have two masses
you have
two springs you add some force there
and if i simulate that you can see
exactly how
how that works out
just to show that it's the same system
that's being modeled
so you gain a lot of intuition for
for um seeing how the real world system
corresponds to the the model system
so to summarize that i think there's
great opportunities for system modeler
we've already taken
the first steps we're taking more steps
and
system model and mathematica together
brings a lot of
um new perspectives to to the education
field
so welcome to part two of this system
modeler applied
presentation my name is andelimos bay
i work as an applications engineer at
wolfram mathcorp
and today i'll be talking about a recent
modeling project that we did in failure
analysis
where we used uh wolfram system model 4
which is the latest version of system
modeler
and the wool from hydraulic library
okay so first i thought i'd just
introduce you
to what i'll be talking about this
during this presentation
so um first i'll introduce you to
failure modeling with system modeler
basically just what we have to gain by
using models in failure analysis
i'll talk a little bit more about the
system that we modeled
which is the flap system of a cessna
aircraft
and then i'll talk a little bit more
about the hydraulics involved
about the model and then finish off by
looking at some simulation results and
doing a failure analysis
okay so why even use
models to understand failures in dynamic
system
well as the systems start to become
larger and they become more complex
just take an entire aircraft as an
example it also becomes more difficult
to understand how failures on a
component level
affect the function at a system level
so taking the aircraft and the flap
system as an example
how would a leaking pipe somewhere in
the flap system affect the plane's
ability to
extend or retract the flaps
so using modeling and simulation we can
answer that questions
and more such as how will a control
system behave
when when a component is malfunctioning
will the failure become detectable
during a test procedure
and can safety procedure a remedy
failure b
and this last point has to do with
testing and designing different safety
procedures
so for example if there's an electrical
failure somewhere
will it recover if i do this or that
and then of course there are more
general advantages with using a
component based modeling approach
such as that you get reusable components
that make it
easy to iterate over many different
designs
okay so to demonstrate how to use system
modeler in
failure analysis we chose to model the
flap system of assassin aircraft
more specifically we chose cessna 441
conquest 2.
and i'm sure everyone in here knows what
flaps are on a plane there are these
hinge devices on the on the wigs
um and this is actually an image of the
of cessna 441 conquest ii
so the purpose of the flap system in
this cessna aircraft
is to change the flight characteristics
of the plane
so the pilot can change the angular
position of the flaps using a flap
selector switch
located in the cockpit so
changing the angular position of the
flaps in turn changes the fly
characteristics
more specifically changes the lift and
drag force
so for example during takeoff the flaps
are extended to 10 degrees to provide
extra lift force
um and in this particular type of plane
the selector switch the flap selector
switch has four set positions
up take off approaching landing and
landing
and these correspond to 0 10 20 and 30
degrees respectively
okay and the images that you see here
are actually images of the real
hydraulic schematics of the flap system
in this cessna plane and it's actually
what we based
part of the model on so it's based on a
real hydraulic system
and i thought i'd just talk a little bit
more about the system
um this first figure that you see here
this is the state of the hydraulic
system during flap extension
and during flap extension the bypass
valve
that you see up here it becomes
energized
which allows pressure to build up in the
system
and at the same time you have a flap
control valve down here
that also becomes energized which
connects these two
hydraulic pumps and the reservoir to the
hydraulic cylinder down here
and during retraction the opposite
solenoid of the flat control valve is
energized just to swap where the
pumps connect to the cylinder
okay so this is the hydraulic system
that our model is partly based on
so now i thought we should take a closer
look at the actual model
um the top level model in this case is
hierarchical
which means that it contains sub-models
in this case six of them
and i thought we could take a closer
look at this model in model center so
let me just
right click here and open it in model
center
okay so this is the top level model and
you can see the six different subsystems
here we have the pilot
the electrical system the landing gear
power plant
and then finally the two systems that
are based on the hydraulic
circuit i showed you before we have
hydraulic power and
the flaps so how do these
compo components in system modeler
relate to each other
how do they communicate so we have
two engines and the power plant model
and these connected to hydraulic pumps
in the hydraulic power model
which in turn provides pressurized fluid
to the flaps
and to the landing gear
we have the electrical system it
contains a number of limit switches and
solenoids and they receive them it
receives sensor data from the other
systems
and then we have the pilot model and the
pilot receives
signals that he can observe or control
for example the angle of the flaps
okay
so now you know a little bit more about
the model
and this image here just shows which
parts of the hydraulic system that make
up the hydraulic power and the flap
subsystem so
it's been divided into two separate
models and i thought we could just
look at these more closely in turn
starting with hydraulic power
so we go back to model center
so this is the hydraulic power model
these light blue and white interfaces
that you see around the edges
are connectors these are hydraulic
connectors
and then we also have electrical
connectors
and these round grey ones are rotational
mechanical connectors
so you can see here that this model is
made to connect to
several different domains which is quite
typical when you're modeling a system
modeler
this model also contains several
components with failure modes and this
is how we've
injected different failures into these
models
for example we have the basic pipe here
and going into the component mode
of this model we can see that it
contains a number of switches
and each of these switches represents a
health state
of the system of the pipe so we have for
example
the leakage switch restricted switch
the blocked switch and the normal switch
which is the healthy state
okay so which one of these switches is
used
that is which is the health state of the
system that's determined by a failure
mode parameter
that we've decided to call fm you can
see it down here
and here you can also see the different
options that you have you have okay
blocked leakage restricted
okay so if you set this failure mode
parameter to for example one
which is the blocked state then the
medium will be routed through here
and through the blocked switch and the
result is a
blocked pipe okay
so moving on to the flap system
this system also contains a number of
components with
failure modes the pipes that you saw on
the previous model
and also these wires and the mechanical
rods
it also contains besides the hydraulic
and electrical connectors that you saw
on the previous model
it also contains a translational
mechanical connector that
connects to limit switches in the in the
electrical subsystem
okay so let's go back to mathematica
so now you know a little bit more about
the model and the system that we modeled
so the next step is to do some
simulations and then some failure
analysis based on that
and for that i have selected a few
different scenarios
and these are first of all nominal
operation which is the case where
everything is working as it should
there are no malfunctioning components
at all
and then we inject the hydraulic failure
a mid-air electrical failure
and then we use that same mid-air
electrical failure
and try to test the safety procedure to
see if that
remedies the problem so let's start off
with the
nominal operation scenario okay
so in the scenario like i said all the
functions
are are fully functioning there are no
problems
with any components and this first plot
that you see here
shows the the actual flap angle and the
flap angle commanded by the pilot
so here you can see that they pretty
much match
not counting the time it takes for the
flaps to extend or retract of course
because the movement is not
instantaneous
okay and then in these second plots um
you have the pressure development in the
hydraulic circuit
and the voltage signal at the down
solenoid which is the solenoid
that controls the extension of the flaps
um so note here how the pressure
builds up during the extend and retract
periods and then once the desired
position is reached the pressure
immediately drops
and looking at the electrical signal you
can see how the
voltage peaks coincide with the
flap extension so let's compare this
scenario
with the different failure scenarios
starting with hydraulic
failure so in this scenario we have a
leaking pipe
in the flap subsystem and i showed you
before how the pipes are modeled
so all we have to do now is go to the
flap subsystem
we click the model the pipe where we
want to inject the leakage
and then just change this failure mode
parameter
to two and that's all we have to do and
then simulate
and looking at the simulation results
here we can see that
looking at the pressure plot that the
pressure in the system is significantly
reduced
and the consequence of that is that flap
movement becomes significantly slower
and you can see it in this first plot
here that the flap angle
doesn't quite keep up with the commands
that are issued by the pilot
and of course that the flaps move slower
than normally
could be problematic in cases where
fast action is needed for example if
you're approaching the runway at a wrong
angle
and that angle has to be quickly
adjusted then you could use that extra
lift and drag force provided by the
flaps
okay and then we move on to the mid-air
electrical failure
so in this case we have injected a pin
short into the up solenoid in the flap
control valve i'll show you how this is
modeled
okay so we go into the flap control
valve
and to the up solenoid and here we can
see how this is modeled
so it contains a number of electrical
ideal switches
and a number of different resistors
and each switch again represents a
different health state of the system
okay so for example if you choose
the pin short scenario uh when you
choose um
set the failure mode parameter to two
then the pin short switch here will
close
and all the others will remain open
which means that the electro
electrical signal will go through here
and to ground
okay so let's look at the simulation
results for that
here you can see that the system
actually behaves
okay as it does in the normal nominal
case
initially because
the circuit breaker is isolated from the
short to ground until the moment the
pilot tries to move the flaps back
up and that occurs around here so before
that everything works as it should and
you can see it also in these other plots
here that the pressure development
looks as it does in the nominal case and
so does the voltage signal
okay so but when the when the pilot
tries to move the flaps back up
then the circuit breaker trips and the
pilot loses all control over
over the flaps and this failure
would actually mean that the plane would
need a longer runway
because the flaps can't be positioned
for landing
to provide that extra lift and drag
force
so let's talk about modeling safety
procedures
with that electrical failure as an
example
so a possible safety procedure in this
case
could be to move the flap selector
switch to landing position and then
reset the circuit breaker
because the circuit breaker would be
isolated from the pin short when it's
reset
and then the plane could hopefully be
landed safely
so how is this modeled
we've modeled this so that when the
flaps are in take-off position
and they get stuck there even though the
pilot commands
commands them to move back up then
the flap command is overridden and set
to landing position
and at the same time the circuit breaker
is reset
i can also show you how this looks
this is the pilot model and this is
where the the emergency flap extension
component
is and you can see that this
safety procedure component also has a
failure mode parameter
and here that parameter decides if the
pilot follows the
safety instruction or if he doesn't so
to see the effects of this safety
procedure we can just
change this fader mode parameter to uh
okay it's all
already set to zero but setting it to
zero and
then just re-running the scenario would
show us the effects of this triggered
safety procedure
okay so looking at the simulation
results here
we can see that it has the desired
effect
and once the circuit breaker is reset
the flaps can be
moved to landing position and the plane
could hopefully be
landed safely okay
okay i don't think i have time for an
extensive summary but
i just want to say that when we did this
model when we created this model
of course we made assumption regarding
the for example the electrical design
and parameter values
but this still shows that modeling
has great potential to be used in
failure analysis
to explore different failure scenarios
like we did here and to
see how faults can be detected and to
test and design different safety
procedures
and i have for those of you who will
download this
presentation i have a few links here if
you're interested to learn more about
failure modeling and
modeling and system modeler in general
okay so thank you for listening
okay so in the previous presentations
my colleagues show different use cases
that you can have with system modeler so
you can create
very complex models and in
in this presentation i'm going i'm going
to show what you can do with with those
models once
you want to take them out of the of the
system modeler or mathematica context
in system mode we basically provide two
alternatives to take out your models
one is once everything is ready you
just export a simulation executable
so this simulation executable is it's a
like any program in your computer it's
just uh
it's an x file in windows that that
contains
everything that you need to to simulate
your model it has a simulator it has
a even a server so you can just
uh copy this executable to any other
computer
launch it and and and you and you can't
uh perform any any
you can run your simulation basically
and the second alternative is by
exporting
what is called an fmu fmu stands for
functional mockup unit which is a
standard that has been
developed and it's adopted by by many
simulation
companies that works for
exchanging model so you you can take one
system order model
and put it export it as into this format
and take it into any other tool support
in the standard
i'm going to show you a few demos of
this
the first case that i mentioned before
it was uh i have a model
i export the simulation executable and
and and i want to use it
so the the simplest way of doing that is
is by
a connecting to the simulation
executable uh
through this to a tcp ip protocol and
you can develop
your own application that through this
protocol
connects and you're able to you will be
able to set
inputs uh read outputs and and control
the
the whole simulation
and that what how flexible is is
is this a protocol so just
for you to have an idea is is what
actually mathematica uses to
to connect to control system other
models
so in into mathematica this is already
built in all this all these
functionality that allows you
to without needing of writing anything
else just
execute mathematica models and you you
can
do all all the things that that my
colleagues have shown before
but i wanted to show you
a case in which we take the
the executable and we wrote a small
application
that connects to the to the to the
simulation and and
gives us a different way of interaction
to the models
so hopefully all my demos work without
problems
so what i have here is just my terminal
and i took
i took this electrical model
which is it's a simple rc filter
that has a variable resistor over there
which i set
the value of the resistor to an input u
and i have a pulse voltage here that
goes through the
rc and i'm reading the output voltage
and i have some sensor here to to get
the
the the input voltage so if i simulate
this model
within simulation center i can see
that this is my my source and this is
the
the filtered output
so what i'm going to do is take that
simulation executable that i already
exported
i launch it so it's it's listening to to
my local computer
on a specific port and i have
an application that that we did
it's with it's called
processing if you know it is it's a kind
of
a java based that allows you to do
graphics
so what you can see is that
now now my my program my processing
program is connected to the
simulation executable and all the
interactions that i defined here is
through the mouse so if i
scroll if i move the mouse down it just
run the simulations so what i'm doing is
retrieving data from the simulation
executable
in graph and making a graphic in this
way and i'm using the x
axis of of my of my application to to
define the
the value of this resistor and i can see
immediately
what's the effect that it has on on this
and this simulation
so you can uh very easily interact with
you
with with a model in this way so you can
stop
stop change values and and i can play
with this uh
so what you can what you can do
is is you can define a complete uh
your own program that uses all
this model that is that has all the
logic behind it and present it
the way you you want
this is this another example in which i
took the the model of a tree tank system
and i wanted to make an application that
that shows how it behaves
unfortunately this program had a
for some reason it's not working in the
what i used to to to the to design this
controller but basically what i wanted
to show here is that
i can monitor in real time the level of
the three tanks and control the
simulation in in a similar way as before
so it's possible to build like let's say
a panel
in which you to which you can interact
and and and if you are let's say
building a the model of an airplane you
can use
the drag components in in
and and use it as it was the real
airplane
and other way in which you can interact
with with models is that
system modeler or that has uh behind the
modelica language
uh allows you to to call external c
functions so if you have
legacy code and is written in c you can
easily plug it
into a model and and and use it into
into the modelica context
one of uh
and since you since it's just c code you
can just
put it put everything into a dll and
then create a modelica library on top of
that
so one one of these use cases is
for those who have been downstairs in
the playground we have developed
this library it's called model plug
that a it's a dll that
it interfaces to an arduino board
and communicates through usb
so once once you have
set up your your diagram in system
modeler you can
easily configure the arduino and start
reading and writing signals
i have one demo here that hopefully is
gonna work and since
everything is homemade uh
it's very easy to break so i hope it
didn't break
when i'm transported from downstairs
here
so what i have here is it's it's an
arduino board
which i made a small panel here that i
use
for different control purposes and i
replicate that into a system model model
using this library
so as you can see i have four knobs that
are that they
are sensors
me zoom in a little bit and
those are these four inputs
that you see here i have four leds that
are represented by these four digital
outputs
and two digital inputs
so just as simple as this you you can
start reading and writing signals and
put those signals into system modeler
so what i'm doing i'm breathing the
three three of the knobs
these three and i'm putting putting them
into
into modelica filters so to reduce some
noise so it's just dragging and dropping
set the cutoff frequency and then on the
other side i have another
arduino board here that
has three servos doesn't fall
there are these three components
and what i just need to specify is which
serial port they are using i just want
to be sure this is com6
this is com5 com5
com6
here let's shoot it right here
so when once the the the model is built
uh and it runs automatically connects to
the universe configures arduino boards
and allows me to send and receive
signals and
and it's not working let's see why
if you have been downstairs i we have
other demos using this library
so if this doesn't work you can always
step
to the playground and i will show you
some more advanced
demos of it
okay so
the the servers are not working but what
you can see there
is that i'm um it's reading the signals
that i'm that i'm moving
from here so i have some problem in this
other board
so i apologize and this is a good excuse
so you can
check the the other demos downstairs
and the last option that i mentioned
before it was exporting
as fa fmuse so that
just a
system model that allows you to take
this model and export it so you can
import it into any other simulator that
supports the standard
so what i have done in this case is i
took a tank model
i exported from system motor
into an fmu and then i have a
national instrument very standard which
is it's capable of
of running fmus so what i'm going to do
is launching
very stand which is already set up to to
read
the the fm fmu that i
exported okay so this is the
very stand that took the system over
model
you can easily take your modeling and
put it into other simulator
and just summarize uh you can't say
there are plenty of ways of taking your
models from system motor and put them
into other context and or
even mix it with with with your
your own software it can be done by
just calling external functions you can
also use model plug to interact with
hardware
or just take it into other simulator
with through the fmi interface